there were so many hotel rooms that got
expensive y'all bought out the house
right so after oh my god man
when they when they called me yeah when
they called me it was court
get up on that bike and we went to court
right when they called me
the district attorney had all my hotel
records right i don't know man yeah yeah
yeah what's that about on the hotel he
found them all and and every time he's a
true story every time i checked in
y'all know
the owner was jerry jones yes coaches
jimmy jimmy johnson yeah yeah
so every alias was jimmy jones or jerry
johnson
i crossed up the two names
there was a player named jimmy jones
this poor guy in all kinds of trouble
with his wife
he crossed up their
i think what i gave it away is when i
kept pulling up in all my cars my
mercedes my bentleys yeah and and i was
sneaking around but the [ __ ]
had playmaker
maybe i should have taken another car
oh my god so that's how we got to the
house yeah
it's so funny i remember leonlette
called me one time yeah
big cat thank god make that great dude
man he's defensive uh defensive line
coach for the dallas cowboys now he
called me and said play vehicle i said
what's up big fella he said hey man i
heard we've been infiltrated
[Laughter]
[Music]
right so so so a few weeks later i'm
sitting in meetings i would like to hear
we getting ready for games getting into
plays
jerry calls me over to
go to the office i said what
what i'm saying come on i'll meet you
ladies and gents to see you now yeah i i
went over i said what's up boss
he said michael
there's a story breaking
about some
white house your head he said uh
he said you know what i tell you now
long as you tell me the truth i can
fight for you but you got to give me the
truth what
wha what what is what's what's with this
story
is it how much truth to it
i was stunned for a minute i just kind
of think okay
he said tell me the truth i'm gonna tell
you the truth he said what were you guys
doing here i said boss let me tell you
we were trying to do the wrong thing the
right way that's beautiful
that's beautiful
so i thought
i thought it was a brilliant plan
actually you know a couple guys throwing
a couple hundred dollars every month and
we got use of a home big old house five
bedroom house it was it was delayed it
was laid everywhere now and it worked
for you it was laid everywhere because
we were like okay we don't want to have
all these cars we will park somewhere
else and everybody shut her over yeah
you shutter over to that so we've been
in the house without all these cars
because we picked up a neighborhood with
older people yeah you want to upset the
homeowners association
man but then you know as like all plans
yeah as you go through it everybody
started drinking and now going and then
you just you get everybody start parking
at the house you say everybody and you
exclude yourself from everybody no no no
you weren't doing any of that at the
white house no the drinking
nothing was the president
of myself
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god dude
yeah yeah be serious be serious
them girls anyway why you ain't about
all that jewelry
but that's okay
it's bad financial planning
right
[Applause]
like you know oh old days back in the
coliseum when the warriors got the women
after they won the gladiators yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's what it was so so you
know that's kind of how i
worked in my sick head now now you guys
are the toast of the town of dallas was
it insane during that run like the
amount of girls coming up to you guys
was it you couldn't even walk down the
street yeah
and and you came when the cowboys were
winning
we and everywhere we went now this was
everywhere we went we had to
when we when we get in the city we would
say we're going to stay at this hotel of
course we would have to send out a lot
of dummy dummy routes on the routes we
were taking people want to line up and
wait on you to ride by on buses and no
matter what they always found a real
hotel
they always found the real hotel yeah so
so and the girls would always be there
man and just they'd be wait they
wouldn't use a goodie being at the hotel
yeah you're just a good host waiting
there yeah the big cowboy fans the
cowboy fans not just waiting inside we
but like they would just find out what
room you're in and then just wait
outside the rooms well they can't get on
the floors because
yeah
we had security carrying every floor
yeah security on every floor but but
they would be waiting outside and of
course then you know
yeah we were trying to get those uh
floor plans to the hotel
around but i couldn't it was uh i
couldn't find the floor plan ocean's
eleven [ __ ]
how can we sneak him through can we get
him through this event
[Laughter]
mission impossible
right right yeah no i was pretty focused
on football i had for some reason i had
messed in my own head that you know i
don't want to weaken my legs before a
game yeah you know so so i i was pretty
good before games unless you were you
know ian
uh a colombian
okay
what about caucasians
all right
i better stop
[Applause]
you